Phoenix 911 where is your emergency
oh
yeah I'm outside the cactus
um the cactus Park
Police Department huh there's a guy
there's a guy with a samurai sword he's
he's hitting the fence at the uh where
the cops come in and out
with the trade is there's like a
suspicious guy with a camera by where
the officers exit their their vehicles
was damaging the fence he's not wearing
a a brown uh tank top he looks a little
mentally Disturbed to be honest with you
he's about five
paid uh 180 pounds is it by like a
vehicle exit just so I understand which
ones yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't know what uh okay
that's okay
no no I I have the address it's a
Precinct so we got them all up here does
he is he like what's going to damage it
well he's not really damaging it but
he's trying to what is it using like a
tool or what's he doing
uh the samurai sword it's like a three
foot sword you swinging a samurai sword
that's fine
yeah well where's your emergency
I would be Cactus Park Precinct 39th
Avenue and Cactus Road
what's going on there there is a guy
outside with a samurai sword hitting the
fence and stabbing through the fence
towards the
where the where the police pull in to
park their vehicles it'd be towards the
north side of the parking lot by the
gates where they pull in I just drove by
there and I was like even on to the guy
he looked he was stabbing through the
fence he just kept hitting it it's a
white male
brown hair a brown beard where it looks
like he's wearing like a white tank top
black shorts
and I just live right down the street
did you see um did you see a knife on
him oh he's got a samurai sword on him
oh Samurai sword and he's flashing at
the fence stabbing through the fence
and that was a helicopter overhead so I
don't know if that's what that's going
through
Oscars provided a to the subject until
fire Personnel arrived the subject was
transported to the hospital where he
died from his injuries the sword used by
the subject was recovered on scene the
officers involved in the shooting have
been with the department for two years
and are assigned to the cactus Park
Precinct